it is Friday again which means I got
part of this week's best stories you can
get all caught up on what's been going
on Bethesda has removed the mandatory
subscription fee from the Elder Scrolls
online so now you can pay or not pay
whatever you want if you're
penny-pinching like me you can go for
the free option now called it the elder
scrolls online Tamriel unlimited within
this edition you'll get all the content
from the current game plus all the
updates and content additions if you
wants to keep walking out a monthly
subscription you can get there so plus
which will give you premium in-game
money exclusive bonuses and access to
all DLC packs so long as you're
subscribed controversial kill everybody
simulator hatred has been given an
adults-only rating in North America this
week I guess I means that the good man
Gabe Newell is letting it stay on stay
in San said would be available anywhere
else the adults-only rating tends to
only be placed on content that has
explicit sexual content but it seems
hatred was a special brand of ultra
violent sony microsoft and nintendo all
have policies which forbid adults only
rated games to appear on their consoles
so hatred won't be making an appearance
outside of PC unless the dev make some
changes steam has also never made games
with the air rating available on their
service in the past so it'll be
interesting to see if anything changes
now that it's been officially rated
there was Windows 10 News of bounds this
week but here's the important stuff
Microsoft are offering Windows 10 up as
a free upgrade for the 12 months after
it's released so long as you already
have windows 8 for PC or tablet or
windows 7 on top of that Microsoft have
also announced plans to support
streaming xbox one games to your PC
using Windows 10 they're currently also
aiming to have the service running at
1080p and 60 frames per second now I
know a lot of people who are super into
destiny leveling the guy behind the
camera included but the dude in this
next story is really really into destiny
leveling blessed with a balance of
little patience and a lot of creativity
redditor Yavin 4 to 7 explained how he
tapes two server mechanisms to his xbox
one controller to continuously kill
enemies the mechanism presses the Mele
button repeatedly Gavin set himself up
in the dark beyond story mission and
killed 3600 enemies overnight the gamer
explained I did it more for the hell of
it to those saying it's pathetic I don't
disagree with you but it's much less an
exploit least effective way to level up
ever and just a bit of fun just to see
if it could be done and no one else was
negatively affected by it
finally this week if you only take one
story away from this video it has to be
windows holographic Microsoft has showed
off their dream of the world filled with
Holograms with the use of microsoft
hololens a headset that runs augmented
reality platform windows holographic the
headset can detect and interpret sensory
information from your environment and
then project Holograms onto it holograms
that you can enlarge your contract
sometimes and probably do other stuff
with it's important to note that
Microsoft doesn't necessarily want this
augmented reality device to compete with
things like oculus rift or Google glass
let me know if you would use microsoft
hololens and what for seriously because
i honestly can't think of a single thing
i could practically use it for at the
moment this week on site I cover off on
five mind-blowing speed runs from
awesome games done quick Skyrim mods
checks out the new equipment and in two
minutes gets a feel for the zombie
apocalypse those are all the good things
worth your attention this week but be
sure to let me know what you cared about
have yourselves a lovely weekend and
I'll catch you again on Monday
you